mondays are now magical thanks to
margarita mondays at el luchador mexican
kitchen and cantina here to tell us more
is andy hopper with el luchador welcome
my friend thanks for having me jc and
thanks for bringing the mask too i feel
like a true uh luchador here with his
mask yeah we were hoping you'd wear it
but we don't want to mess up it's gonna
get stuck it's gonna get stuck
very simple question
margarita mondays what do you guys have
going on so uh very simply we love
mondays we love margaritas so we're
gonna give them away for about five
dollars a piece that's two ounces of
tequila along with some uh agave syrup
and some house made lime juice a little
simple syrup the best uh the best cure
for the margaret for the monday blues
that's how you start your week with a
margarita all the time and i've heard so
many great things about your margaritas
what do you have which one do you have
for us for yourself so here we have our
mango habanero margarita which is a
mango habanero that's that this is all
tequila so we uh that jug right there
and we put some mangoes some fresh
mangoes fresh habaneros in there we let
it marinate for about two weeks so
they're soaking in that the tequila
soaking and all the goodness that is
tequila the worst thing well the best
and worst thing about this is that once
you get it you'll drink it you'll be
like man i don't feel anything oh give
me another
three later you said oh man that's
that's enough you stand up to the
bathroom like you call me an uber and
let's keep going exactly
well go ahead let's put one together
what goes into it so right now we're
just going to put about an ounce and a
half of that wonderful mango habanero
tequila
and as you're making this too describe
the vibe of the restaurant how would you
describe it i love it it's a party it's
fun you go inside we've got great music
playing we got great great service all
of our food is scratch house made
uh you know uh recipes made by chef
lorena chef lorena is our brand new chef
over in henderson she's amazing uh and
and we're just really proud of the
product that we put out for everybody
over in henderson and in mountains i'm
hearing great things great thank you so
much what was this
i got it yeah we got a syrup and this is
about a half ounce of lime juice as well
and then we're going to uh put a little
more ice in there get some ice in there
yeah and i've only made one so
it's all for you guys thank you my
friend thank you
how many different tequilas do you guys
have oh we have 60 tequilas 60 together
60 tequilas yeah like a punch card so i
could check off every tequila that i've
done at the restaurant you know we we
encourage you to try them all there's no
better way to taste uh to taste mexico
than by tasting one of everything thank
you my friends but uh that that that is
only five dollars every monday over at
el luchador it's simply amazing did you
taste any of the tequila no yeah that is
smooth that's why we have the shot
glasses too because we'll make more for
you that is so smooth what's the spice
on there that is tahini yup so uh just a
really cool spice to it
like feel that my friend let's talk
about restaurant week because you guys
are tied into restaurant week what do
you guys have going on we love
supporting three square and what they do
here in las vegas and in henderson uh
we're doing uh thirty dollars for three
courses uh you can start off with
anywhere anything between elote which is
corn
along to a queso dip or the chaparrita
salad move on to the second course tacos
enchiladas burritos and then finish up
with our famous dessert nachos cinnamon
sugar nachos vanilla ice cream caramel
chocolate the best way to finish our
dessert along with five dollar mango
habanero margaritas i'll tell you what
this thing i'm drinking this thing again
because
[Laughter]
it's sending a nice warm chill
throughout my entire body yeah yeah
that's the best way to finish your day
it really is but those are all day on
monday so you know if you get up at all
you know 10 o'clock
monday i'm going to come down today
to monday he's over at uh illusion or in
mountains edge or ella shore in
henderson people are watching right now
what's the website uh luchadorlv.com
thank you so much andy i appreciate my
friend i'm going to do something i
really do i'm going to finish this drink
when go to commercials all right jillian
there's only one glass i'm sorry but
we'll send it over to